welcome back to things you missed I know
it's been a while since you've seen me I
did not upload last week so you've
probably forgotten Who I am my name is
Susie and it's my job to analyze horror
movies for any Content you may have
missed today I'm going to be covering
Slenderman
I guess Slender Man is the actual title
of this movie like there's a space for
some reason perhaps to foreshadow the
fact that this movie would contain a lot
of empty filler but despite Sony's
product placement of their experience
being the highest level of effort put
into this movie I do have a theory about
the meaning of what we saw on screen or
at least whatever going for and I do
think this theory will be worth your
time more so than the film itself so be
sure to stick around for that let's
start by going back to six months ago
when the trailer for Slender Man first
came out and I being seized world did
the things you missed on it one of the
first things that I noticed was that
there didn't seem to be any ties to the
established Laura Slender Man from the
original photos to Marble Hornets to the
symbology we've come to associate with
Slender Man this led me to believe that
this could be drawing more inspiration
from the real-life incident known as the
Slender Man stabbing when two girls
tried to kill their friend with a knife
supposedly with the belief that they
were making a sacrifice to Slenderman
Slenderman of course does not exist and
these girls were mentally ill they
allowed this viral creepypasta story to
alter their perception of reality and an
innocent girl almost paid the ultimate
price for it I'm gonna go out of order
here let's skip to the last line in the
movie the voice-over compares the
spreading of the Slender sickness to
something going viral it also mentions
that some take it too far and try to
summon Slender Man this movie is
comparing the mental illness of these
girls to the viral takeover of a popular
creepypasta and there are plenty of
examples of evidence throughout the
movie so let's go through them exhibit a
the Slender sickness spreads quickly
through the Internet just like the
creepypasta
the very first scene of the movie shows
two girls watching a viral video of a
breakdancing cat
their phones one of the mentions that
she'd like the video better if they cat
were to explode right off the bat we're
showing the influence of viral memes on
their life and how it can make some of
them take things too far then that night
they're hanging out in Katie's basement
and they first find out about Slender
Man from a rumor that their guy friends
are going to try to summon him so they
decide to try it themselves they watch
the video and it causes them to have
some kind of vision and they describe a
weird feeling coming over them I see
that as them getting the virus getting
the mental illness in their head
after Katie's disappearance the girls
recover her laptop and find that she's
been browsing all of these Slenderman
websites she had been on these forums
with posts from users named Mike Clair
savvy 9 9 Pauly with three Y's and a
leak at 93 they would later find out
that a leak at 93 is one of the last
people that Katie spoke with online
before her disappearance and towards the
end of the movie they discovered that a
leak at 93 is actually a girl named
Allison Riley a mental patient this is
enough to at least suspect that the
mental illness slender sickness whatever
you want to call it is literally passed
from person to person online and it's
later confirmed when Ren decides to
message a leak at 93 and it leads her to
go insane that I mean sounding like a
complete nutcase when trying to describe
some bioelectric aura garbage to Holly
drawing a huge amount of pictures of
Slenderman and standing at the edge of
her window contemplating suicide if
you're not convinced look back at the
scene where Ren describes the nature of
the virus after first talking to a leak
at 93
I mean don't literally watch the movie
again that would be awful but just think
back to that scene Ren describes the
sickness as a virus that gets in your
head and uses the comparison of a
computer virus but in your brain why
would she use a computer virus as a
reference point as opposed to an actual
medical virus I'm pretty sure a computer
virus is only called a virus because
it's similar to an actual virus that you
might contract so her wording is weird
on that but it makes sense going back to
the comparison with the real-life
Slender Man stabbing girls because they
essentially made themselves mentally ill
by visiting these web sites from a young
age and convincing themselves that
slender man somehow exists so that
brings me to Exhibit B once you have the
disease that causes a destructive
behavior
at the beginning of the movie they all
have their own dreams and by the end
they've effectively sabotage those
dreams a question is posed in a group
early on you could stay one age forever
what would be each of their answers
tells us something about that character
let's start with Katy
she says 21 that could be because she
sees her alcoholic father and thinks
drinking away her sorrows is the only
way to deal with her miserable life
she's always going on about being stuck
in this town that she hates and it's on
her computer that the video is
originally launched I think she actually
kind of wants to summon Slenderman and
wants to be taken away by him because
she's depressed so she's the first one
to become mentally ill and she's
basically the one that passed it on to
the other girls you could also argue
that it starts with Katie's father I
don't know if being an alcoholic counts
but he does seem disturbed when he
breaks into Holly's house where he
mentions that Katie was never into this
occult stuff before she disappeared how
could he even know about that without
knowing about the whole Slenderman
ritual also when the girls sneak into
Katie's room to recover the laptop the
dad can be seen watching TV with his
usual bottle of alcohol but he also now
has pill bottles which leads me to
believe that at this point in the movie
he too has the Slender sickness but
going back to Katie they looked through
her computer and you can look at her
desktop icons where there are folders
labeled homework pretty self-explanatory
project home town which I'm guessing is
part of her plan to get out of her home
town as mentioned near the beginning of
the movie and a folder called ideas
looks which I'm not sure what that is
exactly but the ideas portion could have
something to do with the fact that
Slenderman gets in your head much like
an idea there are also two files seen on
her desktop one is called founder of the
dot and the other is named a bucket list
I don't know too many 16 year olds who
already have a bucket list and I'm
guessing that's not there for positive
reasons so looking at all of this it
seems that Katie wants to escape town
and her alcoholic dad but the
contraction of the illness leads her to
a more destructive path towards getting
out of her current life Chloe's response
to the what age you would want to be
question is 9 years old this is probably
because her dad died in the military
when she was 9 it's kind of implied
because when they go to make the
sacrifice in the woods to try to get
Katie back she sacrifices the last
picture of her and her dad and later on
when we're seeing slenderman's POV
through Chloe's house you can spot a
picture of her dad wearing military gear
we don't really know what she
to sabotage her dream because she kind
of stops being in the movie for the most
part after seeing Slenderman you may
have figured this out by now but it's
not a perfect movie but I'm just gonna
try to give you as much information as I
can and you can always let me know your
own thoughts in the comments
moving on to red she said she would want
to remain 30 years old and she
specifically cites that the age 30 is
when you're most mentally stable Ren
ends up being the one who's the least
mentally stable having crazy delusions
in the library and really just sounding
like a complete crazy person in her
speech and being pushed to the brink of
suicide so that just leaves the main
girl Hallie
who said that she'd like to remain the
age that she's at right now she has a
good life if she loves her sister and
she's a track star at her school you can
see some of her trophies above her bed
early on her sister brings up the fact
that one of her teammates quit the track
team after getting pregnant and this
establishes Holly's fear of growing up
and taking on those adult
responsibilities so what does the
Slenderman sickness do to her it gives
her a vision of her getting pregnant and
the sickness then spreads to her sister
and she has to give up the life that she
loves in order to try to protect Lizzie
like the Slender Man stabbing girls from
2014 the girls in this movie engaged in
some destructive behaviors one slender
man gets in their head Exhibit C once
you see it you can't unsee it this line
basically tells us that there's no cure
for the slender sickness and once the
characters have the virus they start
seeing the symbols of facelessness and i
lessness everywhere the original idea
for the logo of Slenderman which I don't
think appears in this movie anywhere is
that it's a head with the face crossed
out because Slenderman has no face so it
looks like that idea is kind of kept
intact only in this movie it's
specifically no eyes as opposed to no
face the legend that they read before
watching the video tells them to keep
their eyes closed and their minds open a
bunch of images flash on-screen some of
which look like Illuminati symbols but
I'm guessing they're just supposed to be
like eye symbols there are also some
letters and numbers that are seen
briefly flashed on screen it kind of
looks like programming language and
further ties into the comparison between
slender sickness and a computer virus
after watching the video when they have
their visions of the forest or whatever
it is that's going on there there are
some jump cuts of a girl with a melting
face after recovering Katie's laptop and
browsing some of the Slenderman web
sites for some reason you can see the
HTML code of the sites and the words you
see him or
in periodically throughout the HTML
which doesn't really make much sense but
it does fit in with the I or lack of
eyes no - when Ren is researching the
library she comes across into this photo
if you don't know what this is it's the
original photo from the something awful
forums Photoshop contest I started the
whole Slenderman phenomenon back in 2009
this is where the character was born so
it's cool to see this photo making a
cameo in the movie but when it appears
in the movie all of the eyes of the
human characters are crossed out and
it's probably for copyright reasons but
again it does kind of fit in with the
Iowa's no teeth in Holly's science class
they're studying in dissecting corneas
and when Hallie and Ren go back to check
up on Chloe at her home she has this
empty blank look in her eyes Rena has
some drawings of crossed out eyes in her
room and the hospital's filled with
eyeless and faceless characters like
some grandma whose eyes disappear a
doctor with no eyes and a lady getting
her hair comb who had no face when
Halley's little sister Lizzy has her
medical emergency that's never really
explained you see flashes of maggots
which are tiny little fly larvae that
often make their homes and rotting flesh
such as in the eyes and then Lizzy wakes
up screaming he had no face and then the
final scene with Hallie where she ends
up being chased by Slenderman doing his
best doc ock impersonation she ends up
at the tree from her original vision
where vines grow over her entire body
and the last thing they cover is her
eyes there are probably many more that
you can catch so let me know what you
saw in the comments that brings me to my
last exhibit Exhibit D Slenderman
doesn't actually exist just like
Slenderman was merely a delusion of the
real-life Slender Man stabbing girls
there's evidence in the movie to suggest
that the girls are the only ones who see
or even know about Slenderman with the
possible exception of Katie's dad at the
beginning of the movie the guys are
stated to have some secret plans for the
night Chloe later claims that they're
planning on summoning Slenderman which
is where the girls get the idea that
they're gonna do it too however there
isn't really any evidence that the guys
actually do it nothing happens to anyone
in town outside of the four girls and
none of the guys make any mention of
Slenderman throughout the movie when
Hallie hangs out with
and brings up the video he acts like
he's never seen it before the first
supposed Slenderman encounter scene
turns out to just be Katie's dad
breaking into Hallie and Lizzy's house
and when Slenderman supposedly breaks
into Chloe's house and attacks her at
the end of the scene the camera pans to
the mirror to reveal that Chloe is
choking herself and Slenderman isn't
actually even there when Tom is asking
out Hallie after school she keeps
looking over to the woods where she can
see Slenderman but Tom can't seem to
notice anything out of the ordinary if
I'm not mistaken I think all of the
actual sightings of Slenderman are seen
through the perspective of the four
girls who try to summon him at the
beginning of the movie at least until
the sickness is passed off to Lizzy
later on in the movie so those are my
four exhibits on how this movie is
trying to compare the Slender sickness
to real mental illness there are a few
other things I missed that I thought you
might be interested in hearing about
there seems to be some link between
Hallie and Slenderman the character they
communicate with to learn more about
Slenderman goes by alicat 93 or Alley it
sounds very similar to the protagonist
named Hallie which wouldn't be
significant if not for the fact that
Ally is never shown and seems to have
all the information about Slenderman
then the movie seems to suggest that
Hallie is absorbed by Slenderman or
something at the end because she gets
engulfed by that tree and shortly before
there's a shot where she walks behind a
tree and briefly becomes Slenderman for
a moment before crossing by another tree
and returning to normal and then near
the beginning of the movie when the
girls are all hanging out in Katie's
basement when we come into the scene
they're all talking about porn as girls
do and they're specifically talking
about watching POV porn from the girl's
point of view and I guess that has
something to do with those scenes later
on where Slenderman video calls them and
we see him sneaking into their houses
from his POV I'm not sure if that was
necessary but I just thought I'd point
out that comparison it really is quite
ironic about Slenderman he started off
as a contest entry on the something
awful forums and now in 2018 they truly
have made something awful now if you'll
excuse me I think I'm gonna go watch 8th
grade a third time to cleanse myself of
the Slenderman movie but before I go
please make sure you go ahead and drop
me like if you actually made it to the
end of Slenderman I want to see who made
it and as always remember to subscribe
to Susie's world for new Horrors every
week bring that deathbed
or notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]